speaking of tragedies daily wire has
this as time runs out for the passengers
on the Titans submersible that went
looking deep into the sea for the
wreckage of the Titanic a last-ditch
effort involving heavy machinery and
submarines arrived in Newfoundland on
Tuesday night three C-17 aircraft from
the U.S Air Force reportedly landed at a
cargo terminal in St John's carrying
unmanned Vehicles capable of going 19
000 feet underwater as well as two heavy
duty Hyundai winches emblazoned a huge
roll of cable and two large machines
that's at high voltage on their sides
according to Daily Mail
a forklift truck loaded the equipment
onto six flatbed trucks the equipment
was taken to a port where a ship dubbed
The Horizon Arctic was scheduled to
leave at midnight although the journey
to the area where the Titans submerged
would takes 15 hours
the Titan may be as deep as twelve
thousand feet below the surface and uh
and it's sitting down there as far as we
know on the surface maybe not far from
the the wreck of the Titanic
late Tuesday night banging sounds were
reported coming in 30 minute intervals
near where the Titan went missing with
its passengers
and if you've been following the story
then you know you already know what led
up to this
you have this company Ocean Gate where
they uh this submersible uh very very
small submersible about the size of a
minivan
that goes down to uh survey the wreckage
of the Titanic which is like 12 500 feet
below the surface
and uh they went down several days ago
and
lost touch uh with the people on the
surface and about an hour and a half
into the into the plunge and they
haven't heard from yet
um
and uh this article continues another
concern regarding the passengers comes
from the fact that a 2022 report by a
CBS correspondent David Pogue said the
Titans hatch is sealed by an external
crew with 17 bolts so they cannot open
the hatch from the inside well that's
one you know I don't understand why
people are making a big deal about that
fact there are a lot of interesting
facts about this submersible and one of
the things people are talking about is
that um well it's sealed from the
outside so they can't get out they can't
open it
I don't really understand why that's
relevant here because they're at the
bottom of the ocean so it's not like
opening the hatch would be an option
anyway
um but either way I find this whole
story fascinating I mean just just
thinking about the depths of the ocean a
place where almost no human being has
ever been a place we know very little
about we know more about the surface of
Mars than we do about the ocean floor
then I think these are people
potentially trapped I say potentially
because it's possible a thing imploded
on the way down they're all dead now but
the idea there are potentially human
beings living and trapped down there
um is it's like it's a viscerally
terrifying it plays on every major
human fear simultaneously and it's also
it's also fascinating
um and it's also been depressing at the
same time to see the reaction from the
public to all of this
at least on social media
where people have just been like
outwardly
contemptuous scornful
openly hating these guys who are on the
submarine laughing at their demise or
their impending demise and it's it's
really it's really bizarre to me what
did these people do to you like what do
you have against them in the not too
distant past private citizens used to be
largely that private what's changed well
the internet has changed think about
everything you've ever searched for
watched or tweeted on the internet now
imagine all of that data being crawled
through collected aggregated by Third
parties into permanent public records
that's why to keep my data private when
I go online I use expressvpn there are
hundreds of data Brokers out there whose
sole business involves buying and
selling your data they don't even have
to tell you who they're selling it to or
get your consent one of these data
points is your IP address data
Harvesters use your IP to uniquely
identify you and your physical location
you can mask your IP address with
expressvpn expressvpn reroutes my
connection through an encrypted server
that makes it more difficult for third
parties to find me sounds complicated
but really you just have to open the app
tap one button on whatever device you're
using IF like me you believe that your
data is your business secure yourself
with the number one rated VPN on the
market use MyLink expressvpn.com Matt
walshow to get three extra months free
that's EXP resvpn.com
Matt Walsh show I've just seen these
reactions from people on social media
even people that I know
uh who you know at least I'm familiar
with and I have respect for and seeing
the way they're reacting to it
what exactly do you have against them
what did they do to you why are you
happy that they're gonna die potentially
like one of the most horrific
and nightmarish deaths imaginable
now sure we've all seen videos by now of
the guy who owns the submersible talking
about uh the corners that they cut and
making it you've probably seen this
video but let's play it again
an experimental submersible vessel that
has not been approved or certified by
any regulatory body and could result in
physical injury disability emotional
trauma or death
where do I sign
oh take your shoes off that's customary
okay wow
inside the sub has about as much room as
a minivan so this is not your
grandfather's submersible we only have
one button that's it it should be like
an elevator you know it shouldn't take a
lot of skill the Titan is the only five
person sub in the world that can reach
Titanic depths 2.4 miles below the sea
it's also the only one with a toilet
sort of and yet I couldn't help noticing
how many pieces of this sub seemed
improvised we can use these
off-the-shelf components I got these
from uh Camper World We Run the whole
thing with this game controller
come on okay so these people got into
that tiny metal can piloted with an Xbox
controller and they went 12 000 Feet
Under the Sea to the wreckage of the
Titanic down at a depth where almost no
other human being has ever physically
been and um
and for this reason people on social
media the peanut gallery seem to hate
them they're openly laughing at their
Misfortune especially because uh the
people in the submersible are rich
you know these are rich because a couple
of billionaires down there and I've seen
a lot of that on the internet uh Stupid
rich people
I'm glad they're all going to drown
but I just don't get this reaction I
have to tell you I don't understand it
it doesn't resonate with me
um I go very much the other way I
instinctively have a lot of respect for
people who do daring dangerous even
arguably suicidal things for the sake of
exploration and Discovery I respect that
I wouldn't do it myself
but I respect that the world needs
people like that
and don't don't tell me that oh it's not
exploration it's just rich people on
vacation
stop that okay they're going to a place
where where almost no other human being
has ever been they're going to the
bottom of the freaking ocean you idiot
yes that's exploration the ocean is a is
a mystery the ocean is an unfathomable
mystery that's what you have to
understand the vast majority something
like 80 of the ocean is is unknown
unmapped uh the deepest depths of the
ocean especially are unknown
the very deepest desk the depth the
challenge are deep as it's called
um has only been visited by three human
beings ever in history
the Titanic is not at the deepest depths
but it is two and a half miles down
where very few people have ever gone the
wreck itself has been visited by two
fewer than 250 people
um which is
which is a very small number of people
in the in in you know in history
like you have never done anything in
your life that only 250 people have done
you've never done you have never been
anywhere
that only 250 people have been to
never in your life and you never will
everywhere you've ever been in your life
every part of the globe that you have
traversed
has been visited and seen by millions of
people
okay every time you go on vacation no
matter where you're going you're going
to a place that millions of people have
been here and know all about and they've
taken pictures and it's on Facebook and
everything
um so you have no idea what it's like to
go to a place where in the entire
history of humanity the total number of
visitors could fit into a small
Auditorium
that is exploration and and I respect
that and especially these I think
because people you know you could ask
uh what would drive someone like why
would you want to do that in the first
place and there's a couple answers to
that some one of the answers
in history there have always been people
like this and we need people like this
we need people with lots of money who
are eccentric
and willing to do crazy things like this
the age of Discovery and exploration in
in history it was was fueled by by
people like this the world would be a
much smaller place without them
um so some of that there's some people
are just like this is this is how
they're wired
and then I also think
because we live in a world
where most of the surface area at least
the places where people tend to go are
known and and you know
everywhere you go millions of people
have already been there
and there's not a lot left to discover
on the surface of the Earth anyway
because we live in that world I think
some people just they can't
live with that and they they need to go
somewhere
where other people haven't been
and again I even if you don't share that
desire
I think you have to respect it at least
would I ever do it would I go into that
would I sit in that death trap and
descend into the darkest depths of the
ocean hell no I would not okay but I
respect people who are willing to do
those things especially do things that
I'm too afraid to do
and uh I would think that we all respect
that but apparently we don't and I and
that's a sign of cultural sickness it
really is like this is actually kind of
a good litmus test
when you see people doing uh daring
crazy things
and it goes horribly wrong and you hate
them you know you hate them that and and
when that becomes the cultural attitude
that that's a sign that we are sick that
we are a sick culture hey YouTube thanks
for listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code walls to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there